[Music]
on this Saturday night's Russian
Rebellion reversal instead of a mutiny
the Wagner mercenary group backs off
from Moscow there's an armed Group which
is not supported not to Russia's Armed
Forces roaming around southern Russia
demanding recognition what it says about
cracks within the Kremlin so this thing
is a disaster for Putin for the military
and it's a gift from Heaven to the
Ukrainian
the Titan submersible Mothership returns
to Port what data
great Nations
two great Powers cheers and why the U.S
president is trying to woo India's
right-wing leader
baronessor
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us it has been an extraordinary
day in Russia with the biggest threat to
President Vladimir Putin's leadership in
more than two decades just 24 hours ago
an armed Rebellion by the very Fighters
Russia had hired to help take Ukraine
then this afternoon as the private Army
got to the outskirts of Moscow the
founder of the Wegner group told his
forces to turn around but the damage to
Putin's image had already been done
says his Wegner group forces took
control of military facilities in rostev
on Don earlier today but after reversing
course forces from the mercenary group
have been seen preparing to depart the
city of more than a million people
residents are seen watching and even
cheering as troops load up in tanks and
military vehicles
fighters from the militia crossed from
Ukraine into rostov ondon late last
night this afternoon there were reports
of fighting within Russia's borders as a
convoy of Rebel mercenaries quickly
moved north towards Moscow
now even though it's been a chaotic 24
hours the about face is not uncommon for
pagosian once a close Ally of Vladimir
Putin he's quickly fallen out of favor
taking aim at Russia's military leaders
Redmond Shannon has our top story on how
quickly this crisis was inexplicably
solved
panic and commotion on the streets but
this is not Ukraine it's rustoff on Dawn
one of Southern Russia's largest cities
used as a hub for coordinating the
invasion of Ukraine Russia's Wagner
mercenary group took control of its
streets overnight
other Wagner troops meanwhile barreled
North toward Moscow Mama along that
route this explosion in the city of
voronej as Russian forces attempted to
stop the advance
said it is not a coup to replace
President Vladimir Putin but the
country's military commanders and he
tried to assure Russians these events
will not affect the war effort
the main operational headquarters are
functioning in the usual way there are
no issues pregosian has been at
loggerheads with Russia's defense
minister Sergey shoigu for months
demanding more support for his men on
the battlefield this Rebellion launched
after he alleged Russian Armed Forces
killed some of his troops in an
airstrike
as Wagner convoys approached tight
security around the Kremlin in Moscow
the mayor canceling public events and
asking people not to go outside
Putin vowed punishment for what he
called an armed Mutiny comparing it to
the revolution that toppled Russia's
monarchy a century ago
it is a stab in the back of our country
and our people
Putin's other main enemy Vladimir
zielinski said Saturday's dramatic
events show the Russian leader is
presiding over chaos but then as the
Wagner troops got closer to Moscow news
of a deal pagosian said he was turning
his men around the literal U-turn
apparently brokered by Putin Ally and
Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenka it appears as though Belarus
will be progosian's new home the Kremlin
says he will move there as part of the
deal and criminal charges against him
will reportedly be dropped in addition
Moscow says Wagner fighters who took
part in the Rebellion will also not face
prosecution and can now join the Russian
Armed Forces if they wish pharah
fredman Shannon reporting from London
thank you Redmond
pogosian has said he turned his troops
around to avoid Bloodshed even though
the shattery founder of the Wegner group
has been described as the cruelest
Commander in Russia's invasion
Putin and if Getty pagosian share
relatively humble beginnings in St
Petersburg pagosian a petty criminal
spent much of his 20s in jail one out he
opened a catering company eventually
getting Kremlin contracts earning him
the nickname Putin's Chef in 2014
pagosian started Wagner group a private
military force that has been accused of
atrocities including mass murder and
rape across Africa and more recently
alongside Russian forces in Ukraine
pagosian has recruited up to 50 000
Fighters many of them Russian prisoners
last month his forces seized the Eastern
Ukrainian city of bakmut pogosian faces
sanctions and criminal charges from
various countries all around the world
for now the arm Mutiny appears to be
over but the chaos could have lasting
consequences both within Russia and
across the border in Ukraine where even
the events of the past 24 hours haven't
put a pause on the ongoing War Korea
Israel reports
Russia's Relentless shelling of Ukraine
did not let up even as the regime faced
an unprecedented threat from inside its
own borders at least three ukrainians
were killed in Russian airstrikes on key
the shelling came as Wagner forces
marched towards Moscow this thing is a
disaster for Putin for the military and
it's a gift from Heaven to the
ukrainians a former Canadian ambassador
to Russia believes the armed Rebellion
is another sign the Kremlin is losing
the war
on the same day as the advance the
Ukrainian military announced its
regaining territory near bakmut the
Wagner group captured the town last
month this is going to deplete Russian
motivation which is pretty lousy to
start with the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress believes the upheaval may
present an opportunity on the
battlefield our best hope our best
scenario is that it will allow the
European Army to advance back to reclaim
territory and positions that it will
demoralize the Russian forces uh and and
lose their supply lines in terms of
equipment and ability to keep shelling
and firing NATO leaders remain cautious
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
called his G7 counterparts including
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
while prime minister Justin Trudeau held
an emergency meeting with some of his
cabinet ministers I have been briefed on
the events unfolding in Russia Trudeau
tweeted we're in contact with our allies
and we will continue to monitor the
situation closely the Western world
needs to
intensify the uh the amount of weapons
the ammunition that it's sending to
Ukraine so that it can fully take
advantage of this situation prime
minister Justin Trudeau is headed to
Iceland for a summit of Nordic Nations
the leaders are expected to discuss
Russian aggression in Ukraine and now
the Russian turmoil from within Farah
Julia Israel in Ottawa thank you Korea
the Canadian ship that launched the
ill-fated submersible trip to the wreck
of the Titanic last weekend is now back
in Canadian Waters five people were
killed when the Titan sub imploded while
descending to the ocean floor today the
ship was met by investigators in St
John's eager to speak to people who were
involved our Mike Armstrong is also
there Mike
well far the polar prints pulled into
the harbor here in St John's at about 8
A.M this morning now it did not dock
where it was supposed to dock
the official logged destination was Pier
12 downtown it instead pulled in across
the harbor behind the Canadian Coast
Guard building waiting already
Transportation safety board
investigators so good afternoon TSB
chair Kathy fox says None of the
passengers or crew were detained but
there were interviews and there will
likely be follow-ups the ship had 41
people on board including several family
members of The Men Who were lost now fox
says the tsb's Mandate is to look at
what went wrong and why the U.S national
Transportation safety board is also
investigating the fate of the Titan fox
says they will be parallel
investigations they'll cooperate but be
independent we are conducting a safety
investigation in Canada given that this
was a Canadian flag vessel that departed
a Canadian port and was involved in this
occurrence albeit in international
waters good afternoon there will also be
another investigation the RCMP says the
deaths at Sea Fall under its mandate
it's conducting a preliminary
investigation to determine if a crime
may have been committed that would then
trigger a full criminal investigation
our mandate
is to look at the deaths and determine
if anything contributed to their deaths
that may lead us down a criminal path
one of the things each investigation
will look at is the voyage data recorder
a ship like the polar Prince is required
to have one it records voices on the
bridge so investigators will have a good
idea what was going on in the hours
before the Titan lost Communications and
in those first hours after pharah
Beck Armstrong thank you
the risk behind the rewards coming up
why advances in technology are exposing
new vulnerabilities within Canada
whether it's the internet or AI
technology it has definitely made
everyday life a lot easier for Canadians
in the 21st century not just for
everyday tasks but also for this
country's infrastructure Health Care
even the economy yet all of that is now
more fragile in a world full of cyber
security threats for the West block
Mercedes Stevenson looks into that and
the risks that Canadians are now facing
Mercedes
pharah our way of life relies almost
constantly on what experts call critical
infrastructure things like computers and
satellites to pay at the pump for your
gas your cell phone to call a friend or
family member or 9-1-1 in an emergency
in your bank card to pay bills or take
out money but that way of life is
vulnerable to sophisticated cyber
attacks a Canadian intelligence agency
is warning that our critical
infrastructure is at risk from countries
like Russia and China or hackers who can
hold information hostage steel Trade
Secrets or paralyze physical
infrastructure and Canadian oil and gas
companies are high up on the target list
according to that intelligence agency
this week on the west block Sammy Curry
the director for the Canadian cyber
security Center at Canada's signals
intelligence agency known as CSE granted
the West block an exclusive interview
and revealed the magnitude of the
threats how often would you say attacks
happen on Canada both on government
structure non-private infrastructure is
it a daily event a weekly event a couple
of times a month
an hourly event wow so against the
government we have sensors deployed
across government and on an average day
we block between five and six billion
signals coming against the government
these are automated systems that are
looking for vulnerabilities having said
that we hear about incidents in the
private sector constantly we also asked
Mr Curry for some practical advice for
our viewers in the wake of concerns
about Tick Tock and other apps that
could potentially be used to spy on
Canadians or violate your privacy here's
his advice on what you should know
Tick-Tock like many of the other social
media app requests from the user and
expanded access to a lot of personal
information many of the apps ask for
access to the contact list to the
calendar to your
coordinates that your geo coordinates
where you are you ask yourself the
question why do they need that
information so the message the threat is
real check your privacy settings and
decide what information apps should have
access to we'll have more head for you
free Morrow on the west block pharah
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
and as Mercedes mentioned you can learn
more about the cyber security threats
Canada faces tomorrow on the west block
which airs right here on global
[Music]
rolling at the welcome mat for Modi
ahead the strategy behind India's state
visit to the U.S
[Music]
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi
arrived in Egypt today the two countries
will hold bilateral talks aimed at
strengthening ties it's the first state
visit to Egypt by an Indian Prime
Minister in 26 years
[Music]
and Modi is coming from a four-day trip
to the U.S where he held talks with
President Joe Biden while the U.S has
accused India of engaging in significant
human rights violations analysts say the
courtship is a strategic move Eric
Sorensen reports
this isn't just Pomp and ceremony for
another guest at the White House it's
geopolitics of the highest order two
great Nations and two great Powers
cheers
India has been called the most important
swing nation in the world and U.S
President Joe Biden is trying to swing
its leader nahendra Modi toward the U.S
the challenges and opportunities facing
the world in this Century require that
India and the United States work and
Lead together modi's not an obvious
dinner companion for the U.S President
Biden has long championed human rights
while critics say Modi has cracked down
on political opponents and stoked
anti-muslim sentiments in his country
Modi defended his record
democracy is in our DNA overshadowing
all of that is the Strategic
relationship India now the fifth largest
economy in the world and a growing
political force the global power
struggle that now exists is not new with
the U.S and its allies in the G7 and
NATO on one side and the power axis of
Russia and China on the other between
them India balancing its considerable
and increasing influence it's on the
world stage for decades Indian leaders
from nehru to Gandhi rallied so-called
non-aligned Nations to leverage their
power today India is an economic Giant
on its own exploiting its strategic
interests among the competing Powers
India has increased its oil imports from
Russia tenfold in the last two years
helping Vladimir Putin Finance his war
in Ukraine
and India's bilateral trade with China
is among the largest in the world but
India has also clashed with China over
disputed border regions so Washington's
charm offensive includes more trade and
Military cooperation with India the
United States has become one of our most
important defense partner
both of us have a shared concern about
some of the dangerous elements of the
rise of China the fact that China
presents a threat that we need to
collaborate on I think that brings the
two leaders together prime minister
modi's diplomacy has been called
opportunistic but it's working one of
the defining relationships of the 21st
century India is an ascendant power that
the United States like so many others
wants to harness Eric Sorensen Global
News
[Music]
a turning point for Ukraine next we're
going to hear from an expert on the
attempted Russian Mutiny and how it's
impacted Putin's image in Russia
[Music]
now back to our top story in the
aftermath of what at one point seemed to
be an attempted coup by Russian
paramilitary group The Wegner group
against moscow's leadership the
situation now seems to have de-escalated
but this unprecedented incident has
exposed cracks within Russia and could
have long-term consequences joining us
now is George Beebe he's the director of
brand strategy at the Quincy Institute
George quite a day with evgeny fogosian
marching his Wagner forces towards
Moscow then deciding to turn back what's
your take on the past 24 hours
well I think it's been quite a wild ride
I think uh you know less than 24 hours
ago people were worrying about whether
Putin might be overthrown by a military
coup they're also worrying about whether
the Russian military would be so
diverted by this unprecedented Threat by
this private mercenary Army that they
would have to divert forces from Ukraine
and potentially deal a fatal blow to the
Russian effort there uh now we have a
deal apparently brokered by Belarusian
president uh and
um it looks like pregosian the head of
this private mercenary Army is going to
wind up in Exile in Belarus uh the
Wagner Fighters that were not in open
Rebellion against uh the Kremlin are
going to sign contracts with the regular
Russian military and charges against
everybody appear to be being dropped now
what I think this means is that the
immediate crisis is probably over Putin
is not in immediate danger of being
overthrown by this mercenary Army the
threat to Russia's war effort in Ukraine
has probably been averted for now but I
think this crisis more broadly speaking
is not over yet the the damage that this
has done to Putin's image inside Russia
is probably significant and the
repercussions of this incident are
likely to play out for some time to come
what does it say about security the
state of security in Russia and defenses
I mean that pagosian first of all felt
emboldened to to pull off this but also
to get as close as Hitler did it in 1941
pretty close to the Kremlin
well I think some some of his forces I
think had had proceeded that far but
recognized that while this March was
going on negotiations were also
happening in Belarus uh with pregosian
so my guess is that the Russian military
didn't do some things vis-a-vis
advancing mercenaries that they might
otherwise have done had they not wanted
to undermine uh these negotiations they
were driving up a highway and the
Russian military has a very substantial
Air Force It's relatively easy to Target
convoys that are driving up a highway
using Air Forces so I'm not sure that
this was as close a call militarily as
some are portraying it nonetheless I
think there are a lot of people in
Moscow that are asking themselves how
did Putin allow this situation to spin
so far out of control and that's got to
be injecting some real doubts within the
Moscow political Elite about whether
Putin can continue to keep order in
Russia in the longer term
and then what happens also in Ukraine I
mean you mentioned this contract that
the Kremlin is going to get to a Wagner
of ignorant fighters to sign right but
can can the Russian government really
sever ties between these mercenaries and
progosian
well the thing about mercenaries is they
they fight for whoever's paying them and
my guess is that this was not quite so
much uh a matter of political Rebellion
on a part of part of a lot of these
Fighters so much as it was wanting to
ensure that they're going to continue to
be paid and supplied adequately so that
they can in fact fight effectively and
that I think is something that the the
Kremlin and the Russian military
leadership can ensure and after all I
think one of the things that was going
on here was that the Kremlin was very
cynically exploiting these mercenary
Fighters uh essentially Outsourcing a
lot of the burden of this war on to them
so that it did not have to impose on the
Russian military and impose much
conscription on the broader Russian
population I think that was a real
gamble on Putin's part to try to avoid
making some hard choices and I think
that gamble has shown to have backfired
on him
interesting perspective thanks so much
for your Insight that's George Beebe
director of grand strategy at the Quincy
Institute thanks for your time George
thank you
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm foreign osser thanks
for joining us tonight's your Canada is
Cranbrook BC Jeff Semple we'll be with
you tomorrow until next time take care
of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
thank you